Hagamos un par de ejemplos
graficando ecuaciones lineales,
hay un buen de formas de graficar esto,
lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo
es la más básica,
vamos a agarrar un buen de valores
vamos a ver qué valores toma la ecuación
y conectarlos... los puntos.
Voy a reescribir esto en caso de que no lo vean
"y" es igual a "2x" + 7
y lo que quiero
es graficar esta ecuación lineal
antes de tomar la gráfica
vamos a poner una tabla
voy a tomar un buen de valores de "x"
y ver qué valor de "y" le corresponde
a cada uno de esos valores,
así que por ejemplo,
si "x" es igual a...
empezar con algo muy pequeño,
digamos,
si "x" es igual a -2
¿quién es "y"?
entonces sustituimos -2 en la ecuación
y esto sería 2 por -2 más 7
y esto es -4 más 7
que es igual a 3
si "x" es igual a...
estoy agarrando valores al azar,
o a lo mejor puedo irme
saltando en 2 ó 3 unidades o en 1,
no sé...
pero bueno, ¿qué tal si "x" es 0?
entonces "y" es igual a 2 por 0
más 7
y esto es igual a 7
muy bien
ahora qué tal si...
bueno...
ya que estoy subiendo de 2 en 2
podría subir de 1 en 1, ó...
tomando números al azar...
pero bueno,
¿qué tal si "x" es 2?
entonces ponemos,
2 por 2 más 7
y esto es 4 más 7
que es igual a 11
y puedo seguir graficando este...
puntos como yo quiera ,de hecho,
para graficar una línea
sólo necesito dos puntos ¿verdad?
así que realmente
ya tenemos uno de más
déjenme... déjenme poner otro punto más,
para que vean que en efecto es una línea
cuando "x" es igual a...
es más vamos a ponerle que sea 8,
solo para agarrar un número, un número al azar,
entonces esto será 2 por 8 más 7
y 2 por 8 son 16
y si le sumamos luego
7 nos da 23
muy bien,
ahora vamos a graficarlo.
Déjenme hacer mi eje "y"
aquí justamente
ok
aquí está mi eje "x"
y tenemos un buen de valores positivos
así que vamos a dejar más...
más espacio del lado positivo... ahí está mi eje...
y cuando uso...
cuando... cuando "x" vale -2
es el mínimo... déjenme sigo poniendo puntos...
aquí está el 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8...
Ok estos son nuestros valores de "x"
y luego nos subimos en los valores de "y"
déjenme hacerlo en otra escala,
porque estos crecen de forma muy rápida, así que,
voy a hacerlo en incrementos de 2,
muy bien... aquí estaría
el 2, el 4, el 6,
el 8, el 10,
12, 14,
y 16...
y bueno podría seguir hacia arriba,
pero bueno, vamos a graficar estos puntos,
así que la primera coordenada que tengo es
"x" igual a -2 y "y" igual a 3
así que escribo mi coordenada
vamos a poner el punto,
-2, 3
Ok...
3 más o menos cae por este lado
y este es nuestro primer punto
el -2, 3
ahora nuestro siguiente punto
el 0, 7...
vamos a hacerlo en otro color...
0... "x" es 0,
"y" es igual a 7 y está justo aquí
0, 7
y tenemos este otro en verde,
el 2, 11
2, 11,
más o menos anda por acá...
2, 11...
y el último punto... bueno éste se sale de mi gráfica, ¿verdad? el 8, 23
no sé, ahí estaría muy arriba...
digamos por acá
e incluso pueden ver más o menos,
cómo se sigue comportando ¿no?
si conectamos los puntos
vamos a formar una línea
que conectan todos estos puntos
y obviamente
este dibujo no va a salir perfecto,
no es una línea derechita
pero si tuviéramos una computadora,
sí saldría bien ¿no?
si tomamos más valores de "x"
y  graficamos sus valores correspondientes de "y"
porque en este caso "y" es una función
que depende de "x"
si seguimos graficando todos estos
posibles valores de "x", tendremos,
una línea recta.
Vamos a hacer otro problema.
En el aeropuerto tú puedes cambiar tu dinero
por... de dólares a euros,
ok, entonces...
el servicio te cuesta 5 dólares
y por cada dólar adicional tú tienes .7 euros...
ok, tienes .7 euros.
Has una tabla para esto
y grafica la función en una gráfica,
usa tu gráfica para determinar
cuántos euros puedes obtener
de la oficina con 50 dólares,
y entonces voy a escribir,
euros, es igual
vamos a ver
va a ser dólares...
los dólares...
y de ahí vamos a quitarle 5...
5 dólares ¿verdad?
así que inmediatamente
este servicio cuesta
y luego,
todo esto vamos a multiplicarlo por .7
ok
.7
lo que sea que eso nos dé,
esta relación es la ecuación
que nos determina los euros en términos de los dólares
y si les damos 50 dólares
pues simplemente hay que...
sustituir,
entonces tenemos euros va a ser,
0.7, y en vez de dólares pongo
50 menos 5
así que porque tomaron 5 como
la tarifa, ¿verdad? del servicio,
así que esto es 45
y por punto 7
bueno,
eso lo puedo hacer justamente aquí verdad
45 por 0.7 ,
es igual a 7 por 5 = 35
y llevo 3
7 por 4 = 28
y estos 3 son 31
y como solo tengo un número a la derecha
del punto decimal
solo recorro el punto decimal
una unidad a la izquierda,
así que si les damos 50 dólares tendremos,
31.5 euros
no dólares son euros
así que ya respondimos la pregunta,
vamos a hacer una tabla.
A lo mejor valdría la pena tener a la mano la calculadora,
así que digamos, tengo dólares,
¿y cuántos euros tengo en cada caso?
sólo voy a poner
un buen de números al azar
digamos, si les damos 5 dólares,
vamos...
y bueno, toman 5 dólares de tarifa,
entonces voy a tener
5 menos 5 = 0
por .7 = 0
así que no hay razón para hacer eso.
¿verdad?
ahora, si les damos 10 dólares,
¿qué va a pasar?
si les damos 10 dólares,
10 menos 5 = 5 por punto 7 es 3.5 ¿verdad?
tendríamos 3.5 euros.
Muy bien, ahora,
¿qué pasa si yo les doy 30 dólares?
¿qué pasa si les damos 30 dólares?
A ver...
entonces...
bueno déjenme ponerle mejor 25...
si les damos 25,
25 menos 5 son 20
y 20 por .7 son
14 euros.
Muy bien,
ahora vamos a hacer un último
digamos que le damos 55,
esto... esto hace fácil las matemáticas ¿verdad?
porque le restamos el 5
de las unidades entonces
para 55 nos quedan 35 euros
¿verdad?
¿es correcto?
sí justo.
Entonces tendremos 35 euros
y lo que quiero es graficar ahora esto
todos estos valores son positivos así que lo voy
a dibujar en el primer cuadrante...
todo esto en el primer cuadrante...
Muy bien, entonces los dólares van incrementándose,
digamos de 5 en 5
5, 10, 15,
20, 25,
30,
35,
40, 45, 50, 55, sale...
este es mi eje "x"
voy a tener que ampliarlo
hasta 55
y luego en el eje "y" voy a incrementar de...
5 en 5,
vamos a poner 5, 10, 15, 20,
25,
30 y 35...
ahora sí ya quedó bien....
ahora vamos a graficar estos puntos
digamos si tenemos 5,
tenemos 0 euros,
aquí este es el eje de los euros ¿verdad?
y estos son de los dólares,
los dólares es la variable independiente,
y euros dependen del número de dólares
que yo tengo ¿verdad?
si le doy 10 dólares,
obtengo 3.5 euros
más o menos como por aquí,
si le doy 25 dólares,
voy a tener 14 euros
más o menos por aquí obviamente...
pues mi dibujo no va a ser totalmente exacto,
pero bueno si tengo 55 dólares voy a tener
35 euros
que es más o menos por aquí
y si quiero conectar estos puntos,
debería tener algo que se parece
pues mucho a una línea, si lo hiciera
en la computadora sería una línea exacta, pero
bueno éste..
en éste salió más o menos bien, así que,
¿qué es lo que nos piden hacer?
usar la gráfica para determinar
cuántos euros tendríamos si le damos
a la oficina 50 dólares,
así que vamos... va, va, va, va, va...
muy bien,
y aquí en la gráfica
ok, aquí dibujé hasta...
este punto en la gráfica,
quizás está un poquito incorrecto déjenme...
Ok
entonces 35 está aquí...
déjenme redibujar este punto...
éste debería estar justo aquí,
ok,
éste así que...
ahora déjenme redibujar mi línea...
aquí en 25 vale 14...
muy bien, así que mi gráfica
realmente debería lucir más o menos así,
este es mi mejor esfuerzo,
ahora,
déjenme responder la pregunta,
teníamos 50...
subimos, subimos, subimos...
aquí...
y la persona va a obtener...
digamos nos vamos hasta la izquierda
y más o menos vemos que tiene...
31.5 ¿no?
y esto lo podemos obtener de nuestra fórmula,
pero si tenemos un buen ojo podemos, más o menos,
saber desde la gráfica cuánto tendremos,
por ejemplo en 20,
tendremos...
para 20 tendremos como 7.50 dol...
perdón euros
y la imprecisión de mi gráfica hace que esto sea
mucho menos exacto pero digamos que...
20 menos 5 son 15
y 15 por .7
sí...
anda por aquí más o menos...
si ponemos 20 aquí en la ecuación
tendremos 20 menos 5 que es 15
y 15 por .7 es
10.5 euros
que está justo aquí,
así que
si miras en la gráfica podremos también ver
cuántos euros obtenemos...
Vamos a hacer este otro...
La gráfica...
perdón...
la gráfica de abajo
nos muestra una gráfica de conversión,
para cambiar
el peso en kilogramos,
en peso en libras,
usarla para convertir las siguientes medidas
y tenemos aquí kilogramos
y acá libras
quieren que convirtamos
4 kilogramos en libras
así que nos situamos en el 4,
4 kilogramos
aquí justamente
seguimos hasta arriba,
hasta donde está la gráfica
y 4 kilogramos en libras parece...
no lo sé,
es un poquito debajo de 9 libras
así que un poquito menos que...
bueno digamos... casi 9 libras
ok
no podemos verlo exactamente,
es un poquito menos
pero bueno,
esos son 4 kilogramos,
ahora 9 kilogramos
nos vamos directamente aquí,
subimos todo este camino hasta la gráfica,
y son
20 libras,
sí son 20 libras
ahora nos dicen 20 libras
en peso de kilogramos
pero bueno
ahora nos situamos en 12 libras...
12 libras
y esto lo bajamos a los kilogramos,
que esto es más o menos como 5
5 y medio,
5.5
ahora 17 libras,
digamos estamos por aquí
Esto parece más o menos
como 7.5 kilogramos,
7 y medio
ok
de cualquier forma espero que estos ejemplos
te hayan servido un poco para...
que te hayan hecho sentir cómodo
con la gráfica de las ecuaciones...
Nos vemos en el próximo vídeo.